[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم
عبد القادر عياد
وتتفاعل اخرى في اماكن مختلفه من العالم
هذه هي العاصمه الليبيه طرابلس في يوم
يموت بالتطورات السياسيه رئيس حكومه
الوحده الوطنيه
ثم الى هذه الصور من رام الله في وقت يسود
فيه التوتر بين بسبب استمرار اسرائيل في
سياسه الاقتحامات وقتل الناشطين
الفلسطينيين وهدم المنازل كما حدث في بيت
ريما وفي مدينه جنين في الضفه الغربيه
اما هذه الصور من سانتوس في جنوب شرق
البرازيل حيث يلقي اهالي المدينه انطلقت
منها شهره نجم العالمي بيليه نظره الوداع
على جثمانه قبل دفنه غدا الثلاثاء
وفي مواضيع الحصاد هذه الليله
المجلس الاعلى للدوله في ليبيا يقرر
استئناف التواصل مع مجلس النواب والعمل
على وضع قاعده دستوريه تؤدي لانتخابات
عامه ورئيس حكومه الوحده الوطنيه يتهم
رئيسيا المجلسين بعقد صفقات مشبوه لتقاسم
السلطه وتعطيل الانتخابات
[موسيقى]
اضراب مفتوح لعمال النقل العام في تونس
يعطل حركه المواصلات في العاصمه وولايات
اخرى وسياسيه زعيم جبهه الخلاص يرد على
احالته للتحقيق بانه لن يمتثل لما اعتبرها
مسرحيه سيئه الاخراج
في اقوى ضربه معلنه تستهدف قواتها منذ
بدايه الحرب روسيات اكد مقتل 63 من جنودها
في قصف اوكراني في دنياز بصواريخ هاي مارس
الامريكيه الصنع
والمسيرات الروسيه تقصف ثياب لليوم الثالث
على التوالي
لمواجهه تهديدات جارتها الشماليه كوريا
الجنوبيه تبحث اجراء مناورات نوويه مشتركه
مع الولايات المتحده واليابان تعلن رصد
مسيرات صينيه قرب اثنتين من جذورها وتراقب
عن كثب حامله طائرات صينيه في المحيط
الهادي
في لقائنا اليوميه قبل الحصاد على منصاتنا
الرقميه كنا قد ناقشنا معكم اتجاه مع رئيس
حكومه الوحده الوطنيه في ليبيا عبد الحميد
الدبيبه رئيس المجلس الاعلى للدوله خالد
المشري وكذلك رئيس مجلس النواب عديله صالح
باجراء ما سماها صفقه مشبوغه من اجل عرقله
اجراء الانتخابات في هذه الاثناء قال مصدر
من المجلس الاعلى للدوله ان المجلس صوت
برفض مقترح من المجلس الرئاسي بعقد لقاء
بين صالح والبشري في مدينه بغداد
لهذا الاقتراح بعد تراجع المجلس الاعلى
للدوله عن قراره تعليق التوصلي التواصل
عفوا مع مجلس النواب با اي ارائكم بشان
هذا الموضوع كنا قد طرحنا عليكم السؤال
التالي عن مستقبل الازمه السياسيه في ضوء
الخلافات بين مؤسسه الدوله في ليبيا
45% توقعوا وتعذر مساعي اجراء الانتخابات
وتوقع ثمانيه في المئه الاتفاق على صيغه
للتسويه بينما رجح 47% اللجوء لوساطه
دوليه
هذا سؤال سيبقى مطروح انا على منصهنا
الرقميه ويمكنكم دخول صفحه التصويت عبر
مسح رمز كيو ار الظاهر على الشاشه
لقاءنا على المنصات الرقميه يتجدد يوميا
وتفرق خلاله لقضاء مستجده ومتفاعله عربيا
ودوليا
وتتابعون في الحصاد ايضا
مع تصاعدي الاصابات بكرونا في الصين دول
عديده تفرض تدابير وقائيه على القادمين
منها والاتحاد الاوروبي يبحث تنسيقه
استجابه موحده
[موسيقى]
الازمه الليبيه الى اين يطرح السؤال بعد
تحرير من رئيس حكومه الوحده الوطنيه عبد
الحميد الدبيبه مما وصفها بالصفقات
المشبوهه من قبل رئيس مجلس النواب والمجلس
الاعلى للدوله ودعا الى ضروره اجراء
الانتخابات من جهه اخرى صوتها 49 عضوا من
اعضاء المجلس الاعلى للدوله من اصل 89 على
رفع تعليق التواصل مع مجلس النواب الليبي
بعد الخلاف الذي نسب بين المجلسين على
خلفيه مشروع قرار مجلس النواب بشان انشائي
محكمه دستوريه
ليكون عام 23 لا جديده في الازمه السياسيه
الليبيه سوى التصريحات والتصريحات المضاده
وحالات من الانسداد السياسي في غياب خطوات
فعليه في اتجاه تنظيم الانتخابات
انسداد يحمل رئيس حكومه الوحده الوطنيه
المسؤوليه عنه لرئيسين النواب والاعلى
للدوله متهما اياهم بعقد صفقات وصفها
بالمشوهه لتقاسم السلطه وارشاد العمليه
الانتخابيه بالضمان استمرارهما في منصبهما
بشكل يتصادم وفق تعبيره مع اراده الناخبين
الليبيين
ولكنهم دائما منشغلون في البحث عن طرق
جديده للتمديد لانفسهم او تقاسم السلطه
عبر طبقات مشبوهه خلفك كواليس المظلمه
لا يمكن ان تكون هذه الشجاعه لهم لمواجهه
الشعب اللين وفي خطوه يمكن ان تخفف حده
انسداد السياسي قرر المجلس الاعلى للدوله
في جلسه رسميه بطرابلس استئناف الحوار مع
مجلس النواب لانجاز قاعده دستوريه تؤدي
الى اجراء الانتخابات قرار جاء عقب ايام
من تعليقه التواصل بين المجلسين على خلفيه
تفرد مجلس النواب باقرار مشروع قانون
لانشاء محكمه دستوريه في مدينه بنغازي
والغاء الدائره الدستوريه بالمحكمه العليا
في طرابلس وفي ظل هذا التجاذب السياسي ثم
تمير ان البعثه الامميه في ليبيا يمكن ان
تؤدي دورا ضاغطا على اطراف الازمه وتستثمر
صوت الشارع المطالب باجراء الانتخابات عبد
الله الثاني محتاجين داخلي وهذه المفروض
يقع العاتق الليبيين والحاجه الثانيه جهد
الدبلوماسي كبير من الدول اللي تبحث على
الاستقاء وضع لي والاستفاده من مصالحه
والحصول على مصالحها مستقبلا اعتقد الدول
الاوروبيه وعلى راسها فرنسا وربما ايضا
حتى اوروبا الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
وفي خضم هذا الجدر السياسي المستمر منذ
سنوات تتعالى النداءات لنبذ الخلافات ووقف
التصعيد العسكري الذي انهك الليبيين
تراوح الازمه الليبيه مكانها دون ان تلوح
في الافق ملامح تسويه سياسيه ازمه يعتقد
انها لن تجد طريقها الى الحل الا عبر
الضغوط دوليه وازنه وتوافق الكيانات
السياسيه على خريطه طريق تفضي الى اجراء
انتخابات طال انتظارها احمد خليفه الجزيره
طرابلس
اذا وقد جدد المجلس الرئاسي اللي بدعوه
مجلس النواب والمجلس الاعلى للدوله الى
تحمل مسؤوليتهم الوطنيه لتوحيد الجهود من
اجل تحقيق التوافق الوطني الذي ينتظره
الليبيون لاجراء انتخابات برلمانيه
ورئاسيه في اقرب اجل واعلن الرئاسيه
الليبيه انه ابلغ او ابلغ بتعذر مشاركه
المجلس الاعلى للدوله في اللقاء الذي دعى
له الى جانب مجلس النواب في مدينه قدامز
واوضح انه بناها دعوته للمجلسين على مبدا
تعاون السلطات لخلق مناخ مناسب لاتخاذ
خطوات تؤدي الى الانتخابات وفقا قاعده
دستوريه وقانون انتخابات توافقين
عن هذا الملف يستقبل من طرابلس الناجي
مختار النائب الاول لرئيس المجلس الاعلى
للدوله وكذلك ضيفي من طرابلس ناصر ابو ذيب
المحلل السياسي اهلا بكم ابدى معك سيدنا
مختار الدبيبه يحذر بما وصفها بالصفقات
المشبوهه هل يحتاج المشهد الليبي الى مزيد
من التعقيد اكثر من التعقيد الموجود اصلا
بسم الله والصلاه والسلام على رسول الله
انا لست هنا في معرض التعليق على تصريحات
السيد الطيبه بقدر انا استطيع ان اتكلم
فيما يخص المجلس الاعلى للدوله ورغبته في
الذهاب الى التوافق مع مجلس النواب لايجاد
قاعده دستوريه يتم من خلالها اجراء
الانتخابات التي هي مطلب الحاله الليبيه
ايضا التوافق بين او التعامل او التعاون
بين مجلس الدوله ومجلس النواب هو محدد من
قبل الاتفاق السياسي الذي هو اللي يعني
المواقع في السيارات والذي يعتبر هو
الدستور المنظم للعمليه السياسيه في دوله
ليبيا حتى الان وبالتالي تعاون المجلسين
لا يمكن ان يوصف بانه تعاون من اجل او
تعامل من اجل الذهاب الى صفقه بقدر ما هو
تطبيق
الاتفاق السياسي الذي حدد اختصاصات
المجلسين وكيفيه تعاملهما في ما بين فيما
بينهما للوصول الى تسويه سياسيه تؤدي الى
انتخابات وبالتالي تواصل المجلسين لن
يتاثر بهذه التصريحات لانها طبيعه عمل
المجلسين هو التواصل والتوافق حول المسائل
المطروح طيب في هذه الحلقه ضيفه يا سيد
ناصر ابو ذيب اذا كان ما يجري هو وفق
الاطر المنظمه لهذه العلاقه بين هذه
الكينات ما تفسير رمله بالحديث عن ما وصفه
بصفه مشهوره
باعتقادك مرحبا
[موسيقى]
المشاهدين
لاصل هذا الاشكال الكبير وهو ان مجلس
الاعلى للدوله ومجلس النواب جاء باتفاق
امامي او باطراف خارجيه وليست باطراف
ليبيه لان زي المجلس الاعلى الدوله هو كان
يعني بقايا المؤتمر الوطني
من اجل او من خلال اتفاق امم اتفاق
الصخيرات لا اكثر ولا اقل وايضا حكومه
بيبي جاءت باتفاق امم لننسى ذلك ولكن
عندما استمع الى ضيفك صراحه انا استغرب هل
يعقل من سنه 2016 الى الان ومجلس الاعلى
للدوله ومجلس النواب لم يتوافقه ولم يتفقه
يعني نحن الان انتظرنا سبع سنوات ما هو
الضامن بان هناك بالفعل
احل للمساله الليبيه في الايام القادمه او
في الاشهر القادمه او حتى بعد سنه لن يكون
هناك
انفراج لهذه الازمه وخصوصا عندما نرى تلك
العراقيل مجلس على الدوله ومجلس النوابنا
نتحدث على مؤسسات ولا اتحدث على اشخاص
بطبيعه الحال لان ما نشاهده الان وما نرى
يعني انت تخيل معي الهرم اكبر السلطه
العليا في الدوله مجلس الرئاسي يطلب من
مجلس النواب مجلس الاعلى الدوله الذهاب
اليه من اجل التشاور في مساله القاعده
الدستوريه ويرفض ذلك المجلس الاستشاري
يعني هنا
رميته له بهذا التوافق كل لحظه الاخيره
نعم لدي تفسير وتفسير اعتقد ان من وجهه
نظري وقراءتي منطقي بالنسبه لي هناك ثلاثه
احتمالات ان ذهبوا الى المجلس الرئاسي
فهنا هم اقروا بان هناك سلطان عليا اعلى
منهم هي من تقرر ومن هي بيده الحدث اذا لم
يذهبوا الى المجلس الرئاسي والى ال ال هذه
المشاورات فسوف يكون هناك
حل امم اعتقد من بيتيلي الذي لوحي له وان
ذهبوا الى المجلس الرئاسي وفشلوا في هذه
المشاورات وهذا هو المتوقع وايضا هناك سوف
تكون الكارثه الاكبر اذا ما نراه في هذا
المشهد الليبي ليس المشكل في حكومه
الموجوده الان بغض النظر هو يقودها
الدبيبه او شخص
مختار فيما يتعلق الان بقرار المجلس
الاعلى للدوله هل ستمضون في هذه الخطوه
رغم الموقف المعبر عن قبل السيد الدبيبه
نحن التواصل كما اشرت مع مع مجلس النواب
وال هو الحل الذي يستطيع مجلس الدوله
الذهاب اليه الاتفاق السياسي حدد علاقه
بين حدد العلاقه بين المجلسين وايضا حدد
العلاقه بين
المجلس الاعلى الدوله والحكومه الموجوده
في العاصمه هذه العلاقه مع الحكومه لم تعد
قائمه لا يوجد تواصل مع هذه الحكومه
لتفعيل بروده اتفاق السياسي من التشاور
والتفاهم حول اداره الدوله وبالتالي لم
يبقى امام المجلس الاعلى الدوله الا
التواصل مع مجلس ان النواب اما في مقاله
ضيفك حول انه من 2016 حتى الان لم يحدث
التوافق
فالمشهد الليبي لم يكن مستقره منذ 2016
حتى الان المش هتخلله كثير من حتى همم
العمليات العسكريه وبالتالي همم المجلسين
عفوا
حتى يحدث
هذه النقله
في المجلسين لان الخلافه السياسي يعني له
اطراف محليه وايضا متاثر بطراف اقليميه
وحتى دوليه وبالتالي نسب تاخر الاتفاق او
التوافق داخل ليبيا الى المجلسين هو توصيف
غير دقيق وان كان هم وان كان هدانا
للمجلسين في الواجهه لكن المشهد الليبي
اكثر تعقيدا من اختزاله في مجلسين طيب
ابقى معك سيد همم ناجي فيما يتعلق
بالمواعيد المقترحه او الحديث عن
الانتخابات بشقيها الرئاسي وكذلك
البرلماني المنتظره ما يحدث الان يزيد
المشهد تعقيدا ويطرح احتماليه ان الحل لا
يكون الا بتدخل دولي لان الاطراف الليبيه
مره اخرى لم تستطيع ان تجدها ارضيه للتوا
ماذا عن هذا الطرح
ليس بالضروره الان هناك تقارب حقيقي مع
مجلس النواب نحن اليوم صوتنا على التواصل
مع مجلس او اعاده التواصل مع مجلس النواب
بعد ازاله سبب التعليق وهو المحكمه او
انشاء المحكمه الدستوريه من قبل مجلس
النواب والذي يعني سبقه بيان المشترك بين
الرئيسين ثم ايضا نحن اليوم في جلسه
الجلسه الدوله صوتنا على القاعده
الدستوريه مع ازاله الباب المتعلق بانشاء
المحكمه الدستوريه ولم يبقى في تعد
الدستوريه الا باب تحديد نظام الحكم
والاحكام الانتقاليه وايضا القوانين او
القاعده التي ينشا على اساسها القانون
المنظم لعمليه الانتخابيه بالتواصل مع
مجلس النواب هذا التقارب لم يحدث سابقا
ونحن نحتقد انه خلال اسبوع على على اكثر
سيتم الاعلان عن انجاز القاعده الدستوريه
وبالتالي تكون العمليه الانتخابيه يعني
قريبه جدا اما طيب امام هذه اللغه
المتفائله
ناصر ابو ذيب في حاله الاستمرار في هذه
الخطوات ما الذي ينتظر المشهد الليبي هذه
السنه
ما يقوله ضيفك انا هذا ممكن يعبر على رايه
شخص او او او لا يمكن لا يمكن الدوله
لا لا لا لا لا لا انا اتحدث على ان هناك
اطراف مجلس على الدوله ايضا يتحدثون غير
هذا الكلام وايضا هناك اشكاليه كبرى وهناك
من يريد ان يتوافق مع المجلس الاعلى
للدوله والبرلمان من اجل البقاء في الحكم
اكثر مده هذا شيء نتجاوزه
لا يمكن اصدار قانون من المجلس النواب
بانشاء المحكمه الدستوريه ثم يخرج علينا
صالح ببيان يقولون سوف نجود
لا يمكن لم تحدث في في اي عصر ولا في اي
دوله القانون لا يلغيه الا القانون وهذا
التواصل بين المجلس الاعلى للدوله
والبرلمان وفق بعض الاطراف الداخليه التي
لديها مصلحه فقط في الذهاب مع البرلمان من
اجل انشاء القاعده الدستوريه التي سوف
تكون على مقاسه رف معينه لانهم يعلمون
جيدا بان هناك همم عقد كثيره في هذه
القاعده الدستوريه منها اصحاب البدل
العسكريه ومنها ايضا اصحاب الجنسيات
المزدوجه انا وجه سؤال لضيفه
هل بالفعل يمكن ان على مجلس على الدوله ان
يرفض اصحاب البدله
واصحاب
اسالك سؤال
ماذا لو تم الاستمرار في هذه الخطوات في
ظل هذا الموقف المعبر عنه من قبل السيد
الدبيبه ما الذي ينتظر ليبي هذه السنه
بايجاد التكرمت
انا انا في وجهه نظري وحسب على الدوله او
مجلس النواب لن تتجاوز مدتهم شهر ابريل
لان المجتمع الدولي سوف يتخذ مواقف غير ما
هي موجوده الان لان الاطراف الليبيه
الداخليه يا سيدي لا تريد ان تتفق على شيء
معين وهو الذهاب الى الانتخابات برلمانيه
حل جميع المشاكل بهذه الانتخابات اما ان
تقتل المنتخبات الرئاسيه بالانتخابات
البرلمانيه فانا واكيد لك من هذا المنبر
انه لن تكون هناك انتخابات وسوف يبقى
الوضع كما هو عليه الا اللهم بالتدخل امم
من اجل الفصل في هذه المساله اما غيره
فسوف يبقى المجلس الاعلى
شكرا
النائب الاول لرئيس المجلس الاعلى للدوري
وقد كنت ما معي من طرابلس شكرا جزيلا لكما
[موسيقى]
كثيرا الى الجار تونس حيث دخل عمال شركه
النقل في اضراب مفتوح بعد وقفه احتجاجيه
في ساحه الحكومه بالقصبه في العاصمه دعت
اليها الجامعه العامه
التونسي للشغل على ما تصفيه بتجاهل
الحكومه لما طالبها وامها خاصه مؤسسه
النقل ومن المنتظر ان تنفذ الجامعه اضرابا
عاما في قطاعات النقل الجوي والبري
والبحري يومي الخامس والعشرين والسادس
والعشرين من شهر من الشهره الجاري
في هذه الاسماء وفي تطورات الازمه
السياسيه قال القيادي في جبهه الخلاص
الوطنيه رضى الحاج ان فرع المحامين
التونسيين اعلمه باحالته مع رئيس الجبهه
احمد نجيب الشابي احالتهما للتحقيقه وقال
بالحاج في اتصال مع الجزيره ان احالته
ورئيس الجبهه الى التحقيق جاءت بعدتها من
وجهتها رئيسه الحزب الدستوري عبير موسي
للجبهه بالتستر على الارهاب وقال الشاب في
اتصال مع الجزيره انه لم يبتل لما وصفها
لمسرحيه سيئه الاخراج
انضم الينا من تونس رضا بالحاج قيادي في
جبهه الخلاص الوطني وكذلك من تونس ايضا
محمد ذويب الكاتب والمحلل السياسي اهلا
بكم وابدا معك سيد رضا بالحاج وابدا
بحاله كل من السيده نجيب الشاذلي وكذلك
سيد الحاج الى التحقيق في اي سياق ينتري
يندرج هذا المنحه حسب جبهه الخلاص
ات
تؤكد ان
همم قيس سعيد دخل في مرحله تخبط همم خصوصا
بعد همم انهيار المنظومه الانتخابيه
ومقاطعه الشعب التونسي همم خياراته وتاكيد
الشعب انه يقاطع هذه المهزله
وانطلق في الوعيد وهو الذي اقترح على
السلطه التنفيذيه ايقافات وعلبه ويعلم
الجميع انه كان قدم قائمه في ايقافات الا
ان الصلاه المعنيه رفضت تنفيذ يومها
هي السيده عبير موسى
وفي اطار التنسيق بين قوى الثوره المضاده
وعبير موسي والحزب الحر الدستوري من جهه
وقيس سعيد للاجهاض مكاسب الثوره وهذا
التنسيق معلوم منذ مده تقدمت بشكايه يوم
الثلاثاء 27 ديسمبر على اساس ان الجبهه
جبهه الخلاص تقوم بانشطه ارهابيه
وتتعامل مع قوى الارهابيه وطالبه تتبع
الجبهه من اجل تها من وارده في قانون
الارهاب هذه التهمه المضحكه
قدمتها يوم 27 يوم 30
يقعوا التتبع وهذا الزمان هو قياسي ويؤكد
التنسيق بين قيس سعيد وقوى الثوره المضاده
اللي يتمثلها عبير موسى
الشخص كله من سيدنا نجيب الشابي وكذلك سيد
بلعاج كما قال ضيفه وكما وصف ضيفي بانها
مضحكه
الا تزيد الوضع
عقيدا اكثر في تونس وتطرح علامات استفهام
من الغرض من هذه الخطوات حفظ لهذا الوضع
[موسيقى]
ضد
تجاوز هذه النقطه
لا لا ارى دخل لقيس سعيد عبير موسى في
المعارضه اشتكت بقياديين في جبهه الخلاص
وهما سيد رضا بالحاج وهمم السيد نجيب
الشيبي والاء اؤكد ان لا علاقه لهذين رغم
الاختلاف السياسي معهم بانهما وراء
الارهاب وما الى ذلك اذا لا دخل لقي سعيد
في هذا الملف اجمالا قدمت عبير موسى زعيمه
الحزب الدستور الحر القائدته شكايه الى
النيابه العموميه يتناولتها النيابه
العموميه في اي دوله في اطار الديمقراطي
في ايطار وبالحقيقه او شاب الذي اؤكد انه
لا علاقه بالارهاب ان يتقاضيها بحضور محمد
كما وقع كما يقع في كل دول العالم اذا لا
دخل لقيس سعيد في هذه المساله وهي عركه
وهي معركه بين معارضهتين همم ويعالج يعارض
كل واحد منها طيب ماذا عن الاستثمار في
هذه القضيه في ظل هذا الوضع على الاقتصادي
وهذه الدعوه للاضراب المفتوح من قبل جهه
النق في انتظار دعوه ايضا لاضراب مفتوح من
قبل الاتحاد العام التونسي للشغل
ليست الامور مرتبطه ببعضها وهو
توجيه انتباه الناس الى مواضيع اخرى غير
مواضيع المطروحه واهمها ما يتعلق بالاضراب
والوضع الاقتصادي سيد محمد وهيب
هناك
[موسيقى]
العالم ما بعد برونو وما حدث ومحدث
اوكرانيا الازمه مركبه ولكن لا علاقه لهذه
الازمه بازمه اخرى لو اراد قيس سعيد ان
يوجه التهم لوجهها ولو كان قيس سعيد يمتلك
القضاء واراد ان يواجهتهم لو جاء مثلا الى
قيادات اخرى في حركه النهضه ورطه السياسيه
لا علاقه لشخصين بالارهابي طبيعه الحياه
والقضيه وقدمتها قدمتها عبير روسي ولا
علاقه طريق سعيد بها اذا هناك ازمه
اقتصاديه التي اتحاد العام التونسي للشغل
يسر على انه لا لا مجال للعوده الى ما قبل
25 جويليه بطبيعه الحال عريقه علاقه
الاتحاد بالرئيس ظل التوراه بين همم النقد
وبين الاضراب من حق الاتحاد العام التونسي
للشغل وهو منظمه قوي ان يضرب مدارات ولكن
ايضا من واجب الحكومه اتواصل مع الاتحاد
في علاقه بهم النقل الجامعه العامه للنقل
همم شركه نقل تونس انزل البلد منذ لحظات
منذ ساعات تقريبا
في هذا الاضراب من خلال هذا الفرح النقابي
وهذه الدعوات الى اضرابات همم شامله هل ما
زال هناك مجال لفتح حوار بين السلطه وبين
هذه هيئات النقبيه
باعتقادي قيس سعيد ليس مؤهلا ولم يعد له
امكانيه الحوار هو رفض كل دعوه الحوار
الفائته اليوم تونس تعيش ازمه خانقه
اقتصاديه البلاد على ابواب الافلاس الوضع
الاجتماعي منفجر الوضع السياسي كذلك
منقسم هنالك
معناها صراع ونضال ضد الديكتاتوريه اليوم
لم يعد يدافع على قيس سعيد الا مجموعه من
من الاشخاص حتى الاحذيه التي كانت قريبه
منها همم ابتعدت عنه
ولذلك هو التاجا لهذه المسرحيات السيئه
الاخراج في تتبع اليوم رايناه وكيف تتبع
عيش الهمامي الاستاذ عياش الهمامي لانه
مدافع عن القضاه المعزوليه القضاه التي
وقعت فبركه ملفات ضد اهم وقف معهم وكونا
هيئه دفاع للدفاع عنهم وقع تتبعه همم على
اساس المرسوم سيء السيط المرسوب عدد اربعه
وخمسين تقريبا كل كل الذين اتخذوا موقفا
ضد الانقلاب اليوم هم تحت التتبع
والملاحقه قيس سعيد يعيشوا اخر همم اخر
مراحل حكمه الانقلابي وهو يتخبط ويستعمل
في طرق في طرق ليه اطاله عمري
انا الرئيس السيد سعيد يعيش اخر ايامه كما
ذكر سيدنا محمد سيد رضا بالحاج اسال ضيفي
السيد محمد ذويب ايضا من تداعيات الاضراب
هذا اليوم اضطراب كبير في حركه النقل في
تونس الان المواطن التونسي سواء كان مرتبط
معني او غير معني متابع او غير متابع لكل
هذا استجاب السيا في تونس اصبح الان يشعر
في قوت يومه وفي حركته وفي تنقله ماذا
انتسعت دائره الاضراب بالنسبه لمصير
الرئيس قيد السعيد
الحكومه والمعارضه نعم قيس سعيد ابتعد
عنها تقريبا عدد كبير من الذين كان يدعمون
احزان وشخصيات وهذا مؤكد من خلال انتخابات
17 ديسمبر ولكن حتى هذه المعايره سيدي
كريم هذه المعارضتها نحن نراها تقدم
القضايا واحده والاخرى تقريبا حركه النهضه
التي عماد جبهتها خلاص لم تقدر
لم تقدر يوم 15 ديسمبر يوم 10 ديسمبر قالت
على جامع اكثر من المئات في مسيره التيار
الديمقراطي تقريبا اكبر قيادين فيهما هما
سيف عمرو حمدي وغازي شواشي غادر هناك اسف
سياسيه الشارع على التونسي بعيد كل البعد
عن همم عن عن انه خمس يولد الحاكم او
المعارضه ولكن في المقابله قيس سعيد ما
زال يمسك الاجهزه الصلبه للدوله وما زال
يمسك همم يقود محور العمليه السياسيه وبين
كان القيام باصلاحات تستطيع ان تعود اليه
الاشخاص الذين
لذلك كما القيام الا بالضرب التحميلات
الوزاريه
الاقتصاديه الكبرى
على اساس المحاسبه وكذلك
رضا الحاج القيادي في جبهه الخلاص الوطنيه
[موسيقى]
في تطورات حرب روسيا على اوكرانيا قال
مراسل الجزيره في اقليم جمباز ان انفجارا
كديرا هذا مدينه
سقوط صاروخ على منطقه قريبه من محطه
القطارات في المدينه واضاف مراسل الجزيره
ان الانفجار تسبب في اضرار كبيره في
المنازل المحيطه وادى الى اندلاع حريق في
المكان وامنعت السلطات الصحفيين من التوجه
الى مكان الحريق بينما سارعت فرقه الانقاذ
لاخماد الحريق
بس البرلمانيون اوكرانيون صورا قالوا انها
من جزيره بوتين الواقعه في منطقه خرسون
بين ضفتين اليمنى واليسرى لنهر ديني برو
وقال النائب الاوكراني اولكسي اورشرينكو
ان جيش بلاده استعاد الجزيره التي كانت
حتى وقت قريب في قبضه القوه الروسيه
وفي اكبر حصيله قتل معلنه لروسيا في يوم
واحد منذ بدايه الحرب اعلن الجيش الروسي
مقتل 63 من جنوده في قصف الاوكراني لمركز
تجمع للمجندين في دنياك وقال ان الهجوم
نفذ بسته صواريخ همارس امريكيه الصنع من
جهه اخرى تعيش يوما ثالثا من قصف المسيره
الروسيه مما ادى الى انقطاعات للتيار
الكهربائي
هذا ما تبقى من موقعي تجمع القوات الروسيه
في اقليم دمياط جنوبيه اوكرانيا تقول
وزاره الدفاع الروسيه ان سته صواريخ
هيمارس اطلقها الاوكرانيون على الموقع
وحدات القوات المسلحه الروسيه بالقرب من
بلده في جمهوريه الشعبيه
روسيا المكان المستهدف يقع الى الشرق
الروسيه ليس بعيدا عن الخط الفاصل بين
الجانبين في اقليم دونيت في الاقليم
يتواصل القتال ويتنازع الطرفان السيطره
رغم اعلانه جمهوريه مستقله اعترفت بها
موسكو
الذي توفي الهجوم هو استخدام منظومه هاي
مارس الامريكيه وصلت لمنظمه الى القوات
الاوكرانيه الصيف الماضي حينها توعد وزير
الدفاع الاوكراني الجنود الروس بان الصيف
قد يكون الاخير لهم تتميز المنظومه بدائره
استهداف واسعه نسبيا تعطي القوات
الاوكرانيه يدا طولها خصوصا عند خطوط
التماسي بين الجانبين الميزه الاهم فيها
مارسي دقه التوجيه هكذا تعطي هاي مارس
الاوكرانيين المسافه والدقه في انما لم
يتوقف الاوكرانيون عند حدود البلاد وخطوط
التماسي داخلها ضربات الاسبوع الماضي
تستهدف قاعده عسكريه في العمق الروسيه
اليوم تقول السلطات الروسيه انهم سياره
اوكرانيه استهدفت مقاطعه بريانكا الحدوديه
كذلك تحديدا محطه الطاقه ليتوقف التيار
الكهربائي للاثني عشر ساعه كما قال حاكم
المقاطعه الروسيه هكذا تنقل القوه
اوكرانيه ومشاهدا انقطاع الكهرباء في كيب
والمدن الاخرى الى المدن الروسيه تتهم
روسيا باستهداف البنيه التحتيه الاخرانيه
مسيرات ايرانيه الصنع تملا سماع اوكرانيا
تستهدف محطات الطاقه ليصبح الشتاء اكثر
صعوبه على الاوكرانيين وان كانت صور
الظلام لا تقارن بين الجانبين فان الحرب
تاخذ من عطف اكثر توتر وترا يغلق الطرق
امام الحلول الدبلوماسيه في المدى المنظر
على الاقل
عن هذا المنعطف نسال ضيفنا من موسكو
الخبير العسكري والاستراتيجي اهلا بك يا
سيد بابل والابدا معك في محاوله فهم هذا
الاعلان الروسي عن اكبر حصيله من القتل
الجنود الروس في الدنيا لاول مره موسكو
تعلن عن كل هذا العدد من القتلى الروس في
يوم واحد هل من تفسير ذلك
الدفاع الروسيه بدايه لم تقل اي شيء
ولكنها اجبرت على الاعتراف بعدد الخسائر
لانه
هنالك مصادر في الكريم لان اكدت هذا الامر
بالتالي خرجت الوزاره وذكرت هذا العدد
وذكره الحادثه المؤسفه وقالوا انه هناك 60
اكثر من 60 جنديا قد قتل قد قتل ربع هذا
هو جزء من العدد الاجمالي الذي من الذين
قتلوا ومن الذين
جرحو او فقدوا بالتالي كان هذا حادثه
مؤسفا للغايه وكان امرا طبعا
الاوكرانيين قاموا به من خلاله عن طريق
تدمير كتيبه من الاحتياطي في مكه
بالعمليه الناجحه من قبل الجانب الاوكراني
لم يقتصر على هذه العمليه سيد باظل عمليه
عده ميزه هذا اليوم من قبل القوات
اوكرانيه ولعل ايضا من ابرازها هو استهداف
مواقع حتى في داخل العمق الروسي بطائره
مسيره ماذا عن هذا البعد
استطاعتهم مهاجمه واستهداف اهداف اهداف
عسكريه واستراتيجيه داخل روسيا مثلا هنالك
ايضا استهداف القصفات الروسيه وهذا امر
مهمه وهمم وخطير ايضا هذه انه يؤثر على ان
هذه الهجمات الاوكرانيه كانت محدوده
للغايه لكن الهجوم في مكه يفكانا
ادى الى خسائر بشريه كبيره وكما قلت قد
اثر على كتيبه كامله وهذا امر سيء لروح
المعنويه للجنود الروس ويظهر ان اوكرانيا
لديهم اوكرانيا لديه الامكانيه
ذات الدقه عاليه
وبامكانها ان تع الجيش الروسي
عندما يكون هنالك ربما انضباط سيء وقياده
سيد سيئه من الجانب الروسي
بان الجيش الروسي ربما قريبا سيقوم
بعمليات بريه واسعه هل ترجح ذلك
حاليا
بعد نصف الثاني من شهر يناير او بدايه
فبراير لا احد يعرف بالتاكيد الى الطرفين
بامكانهما ان
يحاولات البدء بعمليه كبيره لكن في الوقت
الحالي اعتقد ان الوضع سيبقى على ما هو
عليه
وضعمي في اراضي المعركه شكرا لك يا سيد
بابا البيكنج هاور الخبيره العسكري
والاستراتيجي كنت معي من بوسكو لارحب
بضيفي من اكياف سير هاي كوزان ومستشار في
وزاره الدفاع الوكاله اهلا بك يا سيد
كوزان كيف تصفون هذه العمليه النوعيه
اليوم والتي اعلن عنها واعلن عن نتائجها
الجانب الروسي بكل هذا العدد من القتل من
الجنود الروس في دنياك
لان يوميا القوات الاوكرانيه تدمر تقريبا
فرقه روسيه من القوات الاحتلاليه ما حدث
اليوم في مكيس هو عمل دقيق للمخابرات
وقوه المدفعيه الاخرى النيه وهذا دليل على
ان اوضاع القوه الروسيات تزداد سوءا وان
وان القياده همم
معسكرات
الذين يتواجدون في مواقع يقومون
بالاحتفالات بها
يحتسون الكحول
وهمم علما ان القوات الاخرانيه تمنع بتاتا
عن همم
المشروبات الكحوليه
لكن القوات الروسيه ليس لديها اي قدره
اخرى لتدفئه جنودها الا هذا لذلك
استخدمت قواتنا المدفعيه هذه الفرصه
للقيام بضربات اضاعه الكثيرين وقتلت
الكثيرين من القوات الروسيه وهذا نجاح
واضح ومن جانب اخر هذا توضيح للقوات
الروسيه
دقيقه انتم في وزاره الدفاع هل لديكم
تفسير لماذا الجانب الروسي لاول مره يعلن
عن كل هذا العدد هذه المره تحديدا
ساره سمير
في وسط القوات العسكريه الروسيه هناك
ادارات
متنوعه وهنا قوات مختلفه وادارات مختلفه
لهذه القوه تنعمل نرى ان بعض الادارات
العسكريه
وبعض التشكيلات العسكريه
وهي تشكيلات غير قانونيه ومتفرده بذاتها
تقوم
ضيفني من المشاعر
من قبل ادارتها العسكريه الخاصه بها ونرى
ان
تشكيلات غير قانونيه ايضا مثل القوات
قديروف ايضا هي لديها مشاكل ونزاعات مع
مختلف القوات العسكريه الروسيه لذلك نحن
نرى انه كل
كل شخصيه سياسيه تشكل قوات عسكريه خاصه
ولديها اداره خاصه بها لهذه القوه لذلك
النزاعات الداخليه الداخليه
الوقت كيف تتعاملون مع الاخبار تقول بان
هناك ربما عمليه بريه واسعه قريبا يقوم
بها الجيش الروسي
النيك
في اقرب وقت
للقوات الروسيه بان تقوم اي عمليات اجتياح
حقيقيه نحن نقوم يوميا بتدمير مجموعات
وفرق من الجنود الروس
وقريبا لن نبقي الى القوات الروسيه اي
قدره على التجديد قواتهم ولن يستطيعوا
بمده قواتهم بالجنود والمعدات لاننا نقوم
بتدميرهم تدريجيا نحن نقوم بتدمير كل
المخططات الروسيات بامكانيه
[موسيقى]
اعلى وزير الخارجيه الامريكيه
التزامه بلاده بشراكه الامريكيه
الاسرائيليه و بامن اسرائيل وقالت وزاره
الخارجيه الامريكيه اكد في اتصال هاتفي مع
نظيره الاسرائيلي
التزامه واشنطن بحل الدولتين ومعارضه
السياسات التي تقوده كما بحث الجانب ان
التحديات المشتركه بما في ذلك تهديدات
الايرانيه حسب الوزاره بدوره قال وزير
الخارجيه الاسرائيلي انه ناقشه مع نظيره
الامريكي عده قضايا منها اهميه اتفاقيات
التطبيعه وتوزيعها والنشاط المشترك لمنع
حصول ايران على اسلحه نوويه
قال قائد الجيش الايراني عبد الرحيم موسوي
ان القوات المسلحه سترد بحزم اذا واجه اي
جزء من ايران تهديدا من قبل الكيان
الصهيوني حسب وصفه واضاف مو في خطاب
مناورات للجيش الايراني ان هذه المناورات
تتضمن رساله سلام وصداقه لدول المنطقه
والدول الصديقه والمتحالفه ورساله اخرى
للاعداء حسب تعبيره واشار قائد الجيش
الايراني الى ان اسرائيل تعيش حاليا في
اسوا حالاتها وانه لهذا السبب اضطر
لتنياهو الى التحالف مع السياسيين
المتطرفين من اجل تشكيل حكوميته
قالت وزاره النقل السوريه ان مطار دمشق
الدولي عاد الى الخدمه بعد اصلاح الاضرار
الناجمه عن الغارات الاسرائيليه التي
استهدفته فجر اليوم وكانت وكاله الانباء
الرسميه السوريه سانا نقلت عن مصدر عسكري
سوري ان عسكريين قتل وجرح اثنان اخرام في
قصف صاروخي الاسرائيلي على اهداف في جنوب
دمشق ولم يصدر اي تعليق بعد من الجيش
الاسرائيلي على الهجوم
لاحقا في فقره المتابعه نعوده لسلسله
الغارات الاسرائيليه على مواقع في سوريا
في نسال ضيفنا عن سياقاتها وما تحمله من
رسائل
كشف الرئيس الكوري الجنوبيه
والولايات المتحده لاجراء مناورات مشتركه
تستخدم فيها القدرات النوويه الامريكيه
لمواجهه التهديد النووي لكوريا الشماليه
اما اليابان فقد اعلنت رصد مسيرات صينيه
قرب اثنتين من جذورها ونشرت طائره لمراقبه
عمليه حامله طائرات صينيه بالمحيط الهادي
اختار رئيس كوريا الشماليه كيم جونغ ايون
هي سنه 2022 بثلاث تجارب صاروخيه وان يبدا
السنه الجديده بتجربه سارقيه اخرى
يحاولوا
الولايات المتحده وحلفائها في المنطقه
خصوصا كوريا الجنوبيه تحت الضغط وكان ذلك
واضحا في خطابه نهايه السنه الذي دعا فيه
الى الزياده من انتاج الصواريخ البالسيه
وتاكد الارقام هذا السعيد اذا اطلقتك اكثر
من 70 صاروخا خلال 2022
امام هذا الوضع زادت كوريا الجنوبيه من
استعداداتها العسكريه واجرى التجارب
صاروخيه لاختبار قدرتها على الرد على اي
هجوم من جارتها الشماليه وقال الرئيس
الكوري الجنوبي ان بلاده والولايات
المتحده تناقشان اجراء مناورات باشراك
القدرات النوويه الامريكيه لمواجهه
التهديد النووي لكوريا الشماليه واوضح ان
المظله النوويه الامريكيه لم تعد كافيه
لطمئنه بلاده
هدد رئيس كوريا الجنوبيه بان النظام
سينتهي اذا استخدم السلاح النووي وهو
تهديد لوحت به واشنطن من قبل يعرفوا كيمو
مخاطر استخدام السلاح النووي لكنه يعرف
ايضا منافع الضغط على خصومه لتحقيق مكاسب
داخليه وابعاد اي خطر خارجي على نظامه وهو
مستعد لابقاء لمنطقه في حاله توتر من اجل
ذلك لكنه ليس مصدر التوتر الوحيد في
المنطقه فالخلافات بشان زادت وتيلتها
ودفعت الصين ايضا الى ممارسه ضغوط القصوى
على خصومها قالت اليابان انها ارسلت
طائرات وسفنا حربيه خلال الاسبوعين
الماضيين لمراقبه حامله طائره وسبع سفن
حربيه صينيه كانت تجري مناورات في المحيط
الهادئه واوضحت ان القطع الحربيه الصينيه
مرت بين جزيرتين نياكمه
للعبور من بحر جنوب الصين الى غربي المحيط
الهادئ ونفدت الصينيه خلال المناوره 300
طلعه انها واحده من مناوره صينيه لم تتوقف
خلال الاشهر الماضيه واستهدفت بالخصوص
تايوان لابقائها تحت الضغط
1727 طائره صينيه ارسلت الى منطقه الدفاع
الجوي تايوان خلال 2022 مقارنه ب 380 قبل
سنتين واكثر من 100 قاذفه قنابل توغلت في
هذه المنطقه
ولاول مره تستخدم الصين المسيرات وترسل
احدى وسبعين منها الى منطقه الدفاع الجوي
لطايوان فيبدو ان كل وسائل الضغط العسكري
تستخدم حاليا في هذه المنطقه
[موسيقى]
عدد الدول التي تفرض قيود ان على
المسافرين القادمين من الصين بسبب ارتفاع
اعداد الاصابات بفيروس كورونا فيها وقد
حتى الرئيس الصيني شيوجن على اتخاذ تدابير
جديده لمواجهه الموجه الاخيره من الاصابه
بالفيروس
[تصفيق]
الامل التي تحدث عنها الرئيس الشيشينغ لا
يمكن رؤيتها هذه الايام
وترتفعالات الاصابه بالفايروس الذي ظهر
لاول مره قبل ثلاث سنوات
منذ رفع القيود التي اضرت كثيرا بالاقتصاد
دفعت بيجين الى الغاء نشر الاحصاءات
العدوى والوفيات اليوميه على مستوى البلاد
اعتراف السلطات حجم متفشل وباء اصبح من
المستحيل تتبعه بعد انتهاء تدابير الفحوص
الجماعيه الالزاميه الوضع يستدعي اتخذت
تدبير جديده لحمايه المواطنين كما جاء في
تصريحات الرئيس شيء وهي الاولى منذ رفع
القيود التي عزلت لسنوات ثانيه اكبر
اقتصادا في العالم
وفق دراسات الاستقصائيه غير رسميه ربما
تكون الموجه الاخيره للفيرس قد بلغت
ذروتها في المدن الكبرى للعاصمه بيجين
ومدينه
فرحه الصينيين بالقدره على السفر اخيرا لم
تدوم كثيرا عدد الدول التي تفرض قيود على
القادمين من هناك في الزياده ولن يتوقف
الرقم عند اثني عشر بلدا ابرزها الولايات
المتحده وكندا واستر عليها وقطر وبعض دول
الاتحاد الاوروبي والمملكه المتحده
واليابان وكوريا الجنوبيه والمغرب تشترط
هذه الدول نتيجه للفحص قبل 48 ساعه من
الرحله او اجراء فحصا عند الوصول الاكثر
سلامه هو قرار المغرب الذي يحضر دخول
الوافدين من الصين مهما كانت جنسيتهم الرد
الجماعي الموحد لدول الاتحاد الاوروبي
سيعرف يوم الاربعاء موعد محادثات ليه
الصحه في التكتل لتنسيق الاستجابه كما
ذكرت الرئاسه السويديه الحاليه
بسياسه صفر كوفد انتقدت الصين وبدونها هي
منتقده اكثر عطله راس السنه القمريه والتي
تستمر اسبوعا بدايه من الاحد والعشرين من
الشهر الجاري لن تكون عطله للفيروسات
والمتحورات المعروفه والمجهوله كورونا
والصين مسلسل يبدو ان ثلاثه مواسم منه
غيرك فيها
[موسيقى]
عوده الى خبر استهداف في مطار دمشق الدولي
في اول يوم تولى السلطه في اسرائيل مجددا
بقدر ما قد يؤكد الهجوم اولويات نتنياهو
المبكره
اسرائيل خيار التصدي لمحاوله ايران تعزيز
وجودها العسكري في سوريا القصف الاسرائيلي
الجديد اخرج المطار الرئيسي والاكبر في
سوريا من الخدمه عده ساعات كما خلف اربعه
قتلى واضرارا في مستودع الى الاسلحه وكذلك
بعض المنشات هذا ذلك الى توجيهي عدد من
الرحلات نحو مطار اللاذقيه شمالا قبل
استئذان في حركه الملاحه في مطار دمشق
واصلاح احد المدرجين اللذين تعطل جراء هذا
القصف هذه المره الثانيه التي يتوقف فيها
مطار دمشق عن العمل منذ يونيو الماضي حين
ادى قصر الاسرائيلي الذات الى تعليق كل
الرحلات مده اسبوعين تقريبا بعدما الح اه
اضرار كبيره باحد المدرجات وفي نوفمبر
الماضي استهدف قصف الاسرائيلي مطار
الشعيرات العسكري في وسط سوريا ادى ايضا
الى مقتل عسكريين اثنين وجرحه اخرين وفي
سبتمبر ايضا قصفت اسرائيل المره الثانيه
على التوالي خلال اسبوع مطار حلب ما ادى
الى خروجه عن الخدمه
لثلاثه ايام كما شنت اسرائيل في اغسطس
الماضي هاجمات على طرطوس بينما تعتبر دمشق
ومحيطها اكثر المناطق استهدافا خلال
السنوات الماضيه وفي فبراير عام 2022
تعرضت مواقع في محيط مدينه القنيطره قرب
الجداد المحتل لقصف الاسرائيلي واجمالا
شلت اسرائيل خلال السنوات الماضيه عشرات
الهجمات على سوريا لكنها ضلت دون اي رد
حتى هذا اليوم
استهداف الاراضي السوريه المتوسط منذ عام
2013 تتجنب اسرائيل تبانيه على نيه لكن
بعض مسؤوليها اقروا به في نهايه عام 2022
اقر الجيش الاسرائيلي في بيان بمهاجمه
مئات الاهداف في سوريا شملت مواقع ايرانيه
وشحنات اسلحه مواجهه الى حزب الله
اللبنانيين في اوائل سبتمبر الماضي قال
رئيس لجنه الخارجيه والامن فيلكنيستا
الاسرائيلي ترامب مبارك ان اسرائيل مسؤوله
عن قصر مطار حلب والهدف ايصال رساله
للرئيس السوري في يناير عام 2019 اكد رئيس
الوزراء الاسرائيلي بنيابه جنه الطيران
الاسرائيلي غاره على مخازن اسلحه قال انها
ايرانيه قرب مطار دمشق
وبعد ذلك باسبوع وقال رئيس الاركان
الاسرائيلي انا ذاكر جنرالذي ازنكوت ان
اسرائيل ضربت الاف الاهداف الاي في سوريا
منذ دون ان تعلنا عن ذلك اذا عن هذا الملف
ينضم الينا من واشنطن الدكتور حسن نيما
الباحث في معهد الشرق الاوسط اهلا بك
دكتور حسن ونبدا بهذه العمليه الاخيره
الاولى في ظل الحكومه او مباشره بعد
استلام نتنياهو لحكومته نحن امام عمليه
تختلف عن ما قبلها
لا اعتقد هذه العمليه تندرج في اطار الحرب
غير المعلنه بين اسرائيل وايران وسوريا هي
فقط ساحه المعركه وليست
ليست هي الطرق الذي تواجهه اسرائيل
قد لا تكون مقتنعه بانه بيوسعها منع
استثباب النفوذ الايراني في سوريا وما هي
تعول على ان لهذا النفوذ سقف تضعه روسيا
ربما تعول حتى على مسائل داخليه ايرانيه
قد تعرق ال- همم هذا الاستدباب ولكنها
المنهجيه قائمه ولا تزال على استهداف
الوجود الايراني حيثما كان وان كان وان
كانت النجاحات جزئيه يعني اسرائيل قادره
على التاخير قادره على العرقله ولكنها في
نهايه السيطره على الارض وبالتالي ايران
ان تسافر على عمليه محاولات محاوله
العمليات بل هناك اصوات رسم تقول بان
اسرائيل قامت بالالاف العمليات حسب ما
يقول تتقول هذه الاصوات الاسرائيليه
نعم وقع الامر بانه ليس سرا بان اسرائيل
هي في واقع حرب مع ايران في سوريا ليست
بحاجه للافصاح عن هذه العمليات كل ما حصلت
المواجهه المفتوحه ومعروفه من يجب ان يعلم
بان هذه الحرب قائمه ايران يعلم ذلك تماما
لان هي المستهدفه المنشات السوريه طالما
هي تخدم المصالح الايرانيه الاستدباب
الايراني بنتيجه همم بحصله الامن
المستهدفه كذلك مثل هنا ليست مساله همم
الاعلان عن معرفه ما هي الانتصار في حرب
طويله لا اعتقد بان سي- قادر على الانتصار
في هوا ولكنها قادره على منع الانتصار
الايراني في المقابل وذلك من خلال عرقله
عمليه الاحتلال الايراني او الاستتباب
الايراني في سوريا على مدى الجغرافيا
السوريه عن جد هذه العمليات او مضمون هذه
الرسائل تقوم اسرائيل بهذه العمليات
ان ترد باجراء مناورات وايضا تقول بانها
رساله بشكل مباشر لاسرائيل وبالتالي كيف
نقرا هذا المشهد بين هذه الرسائل
المتبادله في صندوق البريد السوري
من وجهه نظر الاسرائيليه لاعتقد بانها
رسائل هي خطوات عمليه فعليه اي انه
القراءه الاسرائيليه لبل القراءه الواقعيه
لما يجري في سوريا هي بان ايران تسعى الى
تعزيز مواقعها تسعى الى تعزيز مصالحها
لتهديد اسرائيل لحتى لتكون ورقه
المفاوضه الايرانيه اذا الغرباء امريكا
الى هنالك في المقابل اسرائيل تعتبر بان
هذا الوجود يشكل خطرا دائما
هي في واقع الامر تقوم بهذا السطر تقوم
بهذا الرد انها تمنع الاستثناء باب
الايراني فيما فيما ايران والتي تتلقى
ضربه وكذلك السوريه التي تلقى الضرب بما
لها غير قادره على باب بالمثل لان انا لن
اشهد لا سوريا ولا ايرانيا ضربا في العمق
الاسرائيلي وبالتالي لابد هنا من ارسال
الرسائل للظهور امام الجمهور المؤيد امام
الجمهور المتابع بان القدره متوفره وان
كان وان كان المق فاليوم هو الا تنفذ هذه
القدره لا توضع موضع التنفيذ طبعا هو ربما
في الامر مبالغه ولكن واقع الامر بان
ايران قد تكون مطمئن نوعا ما بانه على
الرغم باستمرار هذه العمليات بالمئات
بالالاف على مدى الاعوام الماضيه فان ذلك
لم يؤدي الى الى نحصار التواجد الايراني
ولكنه ادى الى تاخيره الى تاخير استتبابه
اقول مجددا بانه لربما اسرائيليا القناه
ليست بان هذه العمليات هذه الحرب في سوريا
شكرا سوف تؤدي الى جحر ايران وطرد ايران
من سوريا ولكنها نظرا الى وجود سقف روسي
لهذا الوجود
همم شكرا لكم اعتذر الدكتور حسن عبد
المنعم الباحث في معهد الشرق الاوسط شكرا
جزيلا لك
اذا نصل الى ختام الحص